[Musique]
la situation en Ukraine a rendu évident
la nécessité de souveraineté et donc de
renforcer la filière industrielle qui
permet de fabriquer les munitions les
obus 255 mm
les forces de Tarbes à pleinement son
rôle dans cette filière là
[Musique]
voici un obus de 155 mm qui est fabriqué
sur le site à partir de la réception de
d'acier la particularité c'est que ce
sont des pièces forgées qui font une
cinquantaine de kilos et que nous
forgeons nous forgeons comme de la pâte
à modeler
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la demande est tellement
importante du fait de la crise en
Ukraine qu'il faut à la fois
reconstituer le flux parce qu'il y a
plus suffisamment de flux vers l'Ukraine
et puis il va falloir aussi reconstituer
le stop
[Musique]